[Music]
okay
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Thomas dobajiola
whatever you want to call me I'm here
with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's up
guys what's up we're back to another
episode of the dope usual podcast we're
here to talk about live drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between we're gonna get right into it
guys this is another episode with one of
our favorite people on Earth this is
another Josh Wolf episode thank you for
being here very much oh man thank you so
much for having me I appreciate you and
everyone has been you gonna take your
rooms again we're gonna say it right
away
please explain yesterday we are our
schedules guys it's my fault guys Marty
was filming a commercial right and it
went longer than we expected and you
just told us so I took mushrooms in case
we were still doing this I wanted to be
prepared you know what I mean I don't
ever want to show up and not be prepared
this is crazy
I'm at home
you're still at home
Jacob just in case because Jacob was
like are you taking those I'm like well
I wanna I Wanna Be Prepared just in case
and he was like okay what are you gonna
do
if there's no podcast I'm like well the
worst thing that's going to happen is
I'm gonna be high on mushrooms right
yeah I'll do that and what time would
you set
um my set was at 9 30 and you were high
as a kite peaking oh yeah because
because I got there and
um Sam tripoli's show and it's sponsored
by a weed company the farmer and the
Felon guys oh yeah yeah right and
um and so I'm just sitting backstage so
I must have smoked two two joints and
and uh with the almost three grams and
of mushrooms of mushrooms and um at The
Comedy Store yeah it started to get
later as a performer yeah but I tell you
I'll tell you I've uh so for those of
you listening and I want to tell you man
how many people every weekend at my
shows say to me I came from Yola really
in person I came from Yola they make
sure to wait in the meet and greet lines
to they they say I just wanted to say
I'm waiting just so I wanted to tell you
I came from Yola that's so cool you're
that is so sick it's your fans are dude
they they fit in so well with the people
that come to my shows because we're both
kind of Good Vibes same wavelength yeah
100 but so I've been every Friday night
late show I take mushrooms and I tell
Jacob before the show come get me if
things are going off the rails but in
Michigan I did a two hour
show bam and he just came out and he was
like Hey and I go yeah he picked his
head out he was like it's it's time and
I was like I go how long I've been up
here like 30 minutes he was like two
hours you've been up here two hours in a
row you bump hell of people no everybody
stayed
everybody stayed no did you bump hella
like other comedians oh no it was just
me dude
everyone's stoked for this everybody
yeah everybody say but but last night so
I'm backstage and uh Ryan sickler was
before me it's Sam tripoli's show and I
go Ryan I don't
I don't think like I've never said this
out loud but this is going to be the
highest I've ever walked on stage before
and that's sayings yeah yeah because I I
like to push myself that way when I love
it dude I love to push myself like a bad
dream like yeah I'd love to when you
wrecked us last episode left us grasping
for life you went off and did [__]
comedy
yeah oh yeah he didn't even know what
happened after what happened no no sorry
continue continue of course so uh okay
[Music]
I come
I'm in trouble I don't know if I can
make it I don't know if I can do it and
he looks at me and he goes you were
built for this oh I was like [__] yeah
let's go and I got up there and I
explained to everybody how high I was
and that there may be some unexplained
pauses in the middle of this
touching my mic a lot
were you nervous or not so much no I was
honestly I was excited you know one of
the things as I get older and as I've
been doing this while and Jacob was like
how am I gonna do these mushroom shows I
was like I you know I kind of feel it
out I I want to walk down every road on
this path and so one of these roads is
being [__] up on stage and seeing what
comes out not drunk I think that's
sloppy but like to me mushroom you're
still super creative yeah and so I want
to walk down every path and I want to do
all that [__] and while I'm still out
there having a good time and it is last
night's set dude was so much fun I I
can't believe I will tell you the last
time
the last time I went on stage on
mushrooms at The Company Store was on
tripoli's show
and about two minutes before the set I
was like I gotta poop so bad oh no it's
the worst I was like
I'm so bad he was like hurry I go okay
hurry hurry and so I go poop and I and I
run out on stage and I'm laughing having
a good time and the next day I fly
straight from LA to Orlando for a show
and I take my jeans that I was wearing
that night at The Comedy Store out of my
bag and guys there was [__]
this way
The Horizon the outside of my pants this
way horizontally
above my [__] yeah
and I hold up the pants and Beth goes
what is it I go I think it's [__]
she was like why do you have [__] on the
outside of your pants horizontal I'm
like I don't know I know what happened
oh I still one leg your one leg went out
of your pant leg and you went to pick
them up and that's the only way I went
bam on your shitty ass horizontal
horizontal here's the worst part about
it I said to I was like the worst part
about this is it will not stay yes
somebody looked Jewish all my friends
were around me and they just think oh
Josh smells like [__]
he's like homeless now right
yeah but but I will tell you nobody told
you anything after nobody said a word
was her shirt covering it or probably
not a hard to say what I because I was
shroom and I'm not sure exactly how it
went down you were on stage though I was
on stage with [__] on my pants
definitely turned around a few times oh
yeah dude I'm sure some people were like
is that [__]
and it wasn't like this long dude it was
like a waste it was almost straight
across [__] and the fact that I folded
it and put it in myself
that is pretty crazy
we just posted a clip and you're talking
about how horrible shooting on shrooms
is that the toilet keeps going further
further away not even that Mike yo did
do I have [__] on me yeah yeah I
couldn't tell you
my worst fears on mushrooms is you not
even that you went on stage oh yeah yeah
yeah not even like yo I wouldn't stand
on my couch or like this [__] I'll be
like no I wouldn't perform yeah laughed
cackle that people yeah did two sets one
at The Comedy Store one at the Laugh
Factory gotten an Uber [__] on you got
it in the Uber and thinking back that's
probably why that guy gave me one star
he was like this you really smelled like
[__]
he asked me the meaning of life
[Laughter]
yeah but uh I man for me right now
everything is about fun if I'm not
having fun I'm not I'm not doing it and
and like the mushrooms is part of it
come in and hanging with you guys is
part of it it's fun for the viewer too
it's a little more interesting when you
know [__] Josh is on mushrooms well
this is what I I mean I
I get a lot of people
now that I'm doing this that come to the
Friday shows and go came from Yola
wanted to see you high on mushrooms
and it's a lot of the some of the show
one of my mushrooms I try to get through
stories and see if I can do it and some
of it I
um I just go straight to the audience
and I go you can ask me any question I'm
gonna answer it right now and I some of
that is just genius yeah no you first
okay are these usually in Vegas the
Friday shows no I'm on the road just
wherever oh my gosh I do a Monday show
so I have a residency every Monday in
Vegas that is a ton of fun at Kimmel's
Comedy Club oh [__] cool and so that's a
ton of fun I'm it's just dude like I
said I'm really just the podcaster Jacob
is fun everything is just fun based
right now and I have to tell you outside
of how shitty the weed is I love Vegas I
hear that so much too I the weed's so
bad but I love it here it's so bad but
can I tell you when so we're looking to
buy a house right
and so my Beth was like I'm gonna fly
out and find a house for us to rent
while we're looking
this is a brand new
five bedroom 3 200 square foot never
lived in before house the rent is three
thousand dollars a month what the [__]
yeah dude
what though
the [__]
does blessed first like my second
apartment here dude that's a one two
bedroom apartment here right yeah maybe
yeah and maybe not even depending on
where you're living right
whoa so
it cool it's not only that I mean the
best food in the world is 15 minutes
away from me yeah right I'd like to
gamble every now and then I can perform
the airport's easy but you know the big
thing I like man I like quiet and where
I live is [__] coyotes but quiet
is it kind of on the outskirts a little
bit you got maybe a little space from
your neighbors it's kind of peaceful
yeah you know you know when you're
driving in you ever driven to Vegas
where you're driving in and you're like
on the left
when you're like you can see Vegas and
you're like oh I'm right there but
you're like oh no I have 15 more miles
yeah that's where we are I know exactly
there's a big bus barn on the right
somewhere it looks like oh I'm gonna be
there in two seconds and you're like am
I not there yet that's the spot the 20
minutes past that whistling Willy
Prim California Prim Nevada I love that
that has that old wooden roller coaster
wears a Buffalo Bills that showed you
that thing remember yeah that was cool
dude
so you're in Vegas
you do whatever you want and go perform
yeah
yeah you're in your own little Utopia
there yeah yeah Jacob just moved there
whoa [__] that's why that's why he said
he had Jacob just moved there
you go to Hollywood we're finally in a
place I know that where we're not doing
our podcast on Zoom
well I want to talk about it looks real
like I'm like finally dude because I
told him listen I'm not doing a podcast
again until we're in the same place Zoom
looks good terrible it sounds terrible
the the energy is so different we don't
do a zoom show though yeah it's so
different and so it's so
what we're doing right now is so is so
much fun and I think so different than
anything else other people are doing
yeah absolutely our relationship is
it's different right you don't get like
oh we're friends like I I didn't birth
him but he's mine yeah yeah yeah
by the way dude he'd be embarrassed if I
said this but he hit it then this
is the one podcast
he was so bummed to miss like he likes
you guys so [__] he was like I can't
believe this is really the whole reason
I came down to hang out with my does he
have a plan with his girlfriend he's in
I already knew it yeah yeah that's the
only excuse you have
a night they planned at Disney which is
why they got the Airbnb down there can't
do that and he was like I'll miss it if
I'm gonna do it I'm like no no no no no
no no and I was like and I also said I
said neither one of those guys would
want you to to do that of course we'll
get we'll get Jake light yeah exactly
Little Jacob over here his hair is like
legit yeah it's Greta Van Fleet here
that is yo can we talk about that rant
that band real quick great voices sounds
amazing the fact they said Led
Zeppelin's not an influence on them
makes me not want to listen to him I
agree just say it just say yo hell yeah
yeah I just scream it bro I would love
you yeah are you saying you just
coincidentally happened to sound and
dressing
love the guys yeah but you see uh they
asked Robert Plant in an interview about
them no he's sitting there and they're
like so go to bed oh great great voices
and he goes they said they were not
influenced At All by Led Zepp and he
just went hmm let me kind of like just
chuckled I can't remember what he said
but he said something like thank you
thank you yeah [__]
[__] even you just gotta come clean
come on come on right I mean we all have
eyes and ears yeah
some of it's identical where I'm like
wait what song is this oh what it's not
even the Zeppelin my walk on my walk-on
song is Safari song it's good it's a
good song I [__] love that song and
the older people in my audience like
I've never heard that Zeppelin song I'm
like that's because
it's not Zeppelin
yeah that's exactly why
um your girl's new studio Looks So
Awesome by the way can we talk about the
show yeah for everyone out there how can
they go find your show with you and Jake
it's called hey man
and uh and it you can find it on my
YouTube channel or the clips but it's on
Spotify and iTunes and everywhere you
find it hey man it's spelled with three
A's because he was like that's how you
say it so that's how we're writing it
which I thought was fun but I'll tell
you something man
maybe my favorite because he tour we he
and I tour together now right so it's
just a two-man show he's a road veteran
at this point yeah he does we do a q a
at the end of the show it's far and away
my favorite part not only because I
think it's the funniest and not only I
think people end up liking it the most
even people who are just straight comedy
fans because
dude if I'm gonna tell you something
that I and I didn't know this until I
started touring with him and dad started
coming up to me and kids were coming up
to him he was like not only is it funny
but your relationship is not only
inspirational it's aspirational
and I was like oh [__] and they were
like I had a guy tell me you're doing
this is the first thing my son has ever
he's 25 that's the first thing he's ever
asked me to do with him oh wow and he
was like thank you very much for that
and I was like he said he's like you
guys are making a difference for for
people's relationships and I was like
that is so [__] if you think about it
that way like oh look at his dad like oh
this is Dad yeah yeah
and then I could see how that could open
it's an icebreaker dude it's so cool
um but the the podcast is like every
week he accidentally admits something
that he did when he was a kid that I
didn't know like he was like it's like
that time I stole your car and I was
like what and he's like I didn't tell
you I stole the car I'm like no he goes
like because first of all I used to
steal your car like two three tights a
week and just do donuts in the parking
lot of them
don't I'm like what are you talking
about right now let alone cause
attention you're gonna do donuts in my
car and so
we talk about that but there's always
generational [__]
um because my idea of what hip-hop is
and his idea of what hip-hop is are like
two completely different worlds you know
what's crazy though the people that he
likes are inspired by the people that
you like 100 100 that just keeps going
but he was like uh uh uh I just like the
old school beats more like what is the
top Hip-Hop lifetime List look like for
you
well I'll tell you what man
um I like to see some old school
one-hitters like there's a band called
UTFO that sang a song called Roxanne
Roxanne Roxanne yeah yeah that's I I
guess that's hip-hop I would say more
like it's old school hip-hop but I like
Curtis blow dope uh I like KRS one cool
um the second concept I ever saw was Run
DMC nice
um they played playing a tiny little
venue at UMass Amherst
um but I you know when I was in high
school and my brother
and it really got me into the culture at
the time like both part of like uh um a
break dancing group
and uh oh too [__] [__] yeah dude
you're looking at J-Rock stop your
numbers Jay Rock come on man you watch
Trailer Park Boys no
they always call Marty j-rod is that
right
incredible he's a rapper dude from the
trailer yeah yeah so we did we were deep
in all that [__] yeah
his name was Mr tick tock
he's a gangster Mexican
I had some dope ass parachute pants I
can we've seen you we've seen pictures
of you you looked
like this yeah yeah yeah very much
yeah man but
so that uh I don't know how we got it oh
Jacob's hip hop and my hip-hop oh yeah
oh yeah so like I I guess I get it but
like guys like future for me I just
don't like the music I don't I like I
like what's that um
what's the name of that [__] new band
but they kind of have old school Beats
[Music]
and they're not gonna be new to you oh
run the jewels with uh Killer Mike right
kind of they have kind of more old
school beats to me well killer Mike's uh
he's older also yeah that's why it's
Killer Mike and
ASAP Rock
I'm wrong I'm wrong and so what when you
listen to when you were growing up who
were your guys like I I'm I'm with the
uh uh like I loved Curtis blow
rapping basketball yeah I just loved
honestly honestly why I like
country music in the lyrics I like the
Simplicity I loved Nirvana but if I
can't understand your lyrics like what
is that any of that mean
if the music for Nirvana what didn't
speak to me as much as it did I would
have been out on the lyrics but like old
school hip-hop I like the Simplicity of
the lyrics and they're just telling you
a quick little instructional video yeah
yeah that's pretty much how you would
you like yeah I like getting added on to
a job yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what it
sounded like and then I did this yeah
that's it that's yeah yeah at the end
that's just so dude you like what you
like just riding around at the gym
whatever is it normally music is it
podcast are you listening to YouTube
[__] books what is it normally traveling
in the car I've gotten into just
podcasts oh okay in the gym it's all
music I I don't I can't say anything
every time or do you switch it up no I
mean I have prop no
no no no it depends on the body part or
what exercises I'm doing or or it
depends on the this is my this is my
pelvic thrust [__] yeah yeah that's all
Marvin Gaye
yeah no but like if I'm if it's leg day
raging is the machine if it's leg day I
love it raging is a machine is happening
nice it's happening it's incredible yeah
but by the way the black when I was here
last time the mushroom show
I think
did I I be honest I think I was pretty
sick then did I look real thin
on that show was this before that or
after that remember we didn't know
anything about you being sick oh dude
because I it must have been aft it must
have been before because I I was like 15
pounds lighter than I am now
it was a weird time but I forget if it
was that if it was around that time if I
was like it might have been you're
always like kind of skinny and shredded
yeah my dad would tell me even a
starving rat has abs and I was like okay
I don't
uh but yeah no no no I wonder I've I've
forgotten if it was around that time or
before I'll have to go back and look
at this dude what happened uh oh were
you like six seconds yeah I ended up I
had mercury poisoning I didn't know you
told me this and you said please don't
say anything because right I'm doing
some [__] and testing
that's right what was it from again
I I'm an old dude so I had silver
feelings
and one cracked
during covid and I swallowed half of it
but I didn't I didn't think that doesn't
be bad for me and that when I told the
dentist he was like hey dude you need to
come in tomorrow I go with this was six
months ago he was like what and he was
like first you need to go to the doctor
and then come see me and I said why he
goes you swallow that spilling and I
said half of it he goes the other half
is leaking into your body every day he
said that's straight mercury poisoning
he goes how you been feeling I go not
great and he was like yeah you know what
else can you not put poisonous [__] in
my mouth to begin with you what yeah I
mean it's just inside of my mind I don't
remember when they stopped doing that
because you guys that you were too young
for that [__] right they never put the
silver in your mouth
I have no idea
have you ever looked in the tooth and
seen Silver well then you don't have
silver in your mouth no you're clean
yeah yeah yeah but it has some cavities
as a kid but over poor as [__] I
remember going to the dentist
I for real I don't I put some spearmint
gum right on top of it I was very lucky
[__] yeah what is mercury poisoning yeah
I wasn't so is it better yeah that you
gotta take this [__] yeah you gotta take
stuff that they're they're called
chelators and they pull the Mercury out
and then you got to take a binder which
grabs everything and pulls it out of
your body
so it's just going to take it's when you
have a lot of it it's not it wasn't
super comfortable but dude I feel like a
[__] new person
what the [__] some I've never heard
you've never heard no dude you know
people out here get it from eating too
much Sushi I've heard of that yeah I've
heard of the and uh tuna yeah tuna's got
a lot of careful Mercury like for real
oh God bigger fish
have a lot of mercury because they eat
small fish and all so it's a cumulative
thing so small fish you don't have to
worry about it but bigger fish like tuna
I love that we just learned some [__]
don't die yeah everybody if you feel
lazy it's not just enjoy your tuna yeah
eat tuna all [__] day yeah dude well
good luck you're still going hard with
the shrooms mid mercury poisoning is
kind of the point though yeah yeah you
know oh wait you said you you like I'm
eating straight mold yeah yeah that's
what I said right
that would be it yeah yeah but I
I was trying everything to feel better
um those little butterscotches you had
were [__] deceiving I didn't even
plan on taking mushrooms oh well you
didn't really you took oh yeah a small
portion yeah you're beautiful you do can
we come back
that night you do not know what happened
yeah what happened once I left
as you leave as we as you stop staring
at the sky for 30 minutes and Jake's
like
he was doing this
he said please please please close your
door because you kept sticking your hair
out the door and you're like the [__]
moon but the moon was crazy looking so
I'll admit that I stared at it with you
I'm just saying like why was I [__]
no it's fake
and then you got in the car and left we
go back in I'm like Marty thank you so
much for holding it down because I'm
tripping I look at Marty's eyes and
they're this [__] big and he's like
that because what are you saying wait
what they smacked the [__] out of him
you did really well dude I had no idea
I thought the whole time to my left that
Marty was holding it down yeah dude
everything I had that was like uh you
were like a race car driver you just had
to concentrate the whole [__] way
exactly what's going on I didn't know
but oh no we leave
how long did were you here did you leave
right away 20 minutes later Rosie drives
me home
us home
I get in my bed oh we talked about this
on the show I get in my bed Josh
and some [__] happened
was in my bed and then my like
lights in my room of the chandelier
thing started turning into some globe
thing and then I had my blanket over my
head you know when you have like your
like under your feet and you can stretch
your blanket kind of tight over my head
like a little cocoon
in my room and Rosie was making food for
her so I can't remember I was by myself
and I told you I was like and then they
started talking to me oh no but bad [__]
from The Shadow
and then good [__] from
the light but I was over I was outside
of my own head looking at myself under
the sheet like that like
you're not gonna fall for this [__]
right talking about the bad [__] yeah
and I told you we talked about the show
right
she was like yo
come on you're almost there like you're
almost there just do these things and
you'll be on TV like you'll be it like
that's it that's all you need the
biggest show just do this and it's just
showing activities and it started
showing me people's face like they did
it they did it they did it come on it's
like nothing's gonna happen and I kept
going you [__] idiot you're only
talking to this dumbest you could have
said [__] you yeah and I remember I was
like [__] you and then I was like around
myself it was the weirdest [__] but I
told you it was like yo just do this
you can do this and look what look where
they're at now it was like some evil
like cellular
100 I kept thinking like why is this
happening
all the Rosie's just like why is he
staying
that's amazing you had a sleepover with
yourself
you see I could see myself it was eight
in the afternoon it was eight at night
it was that's right yeah so I'm over
home just like tripping going no I don't
want to stop myself I didn't know what
was happening but uh the night was nuts
and then we watched peaky blinders oh no
and the guy the main character's face
started just like form like forming off
and trailing off and then I got stuck on
that show and watched the whole show oh
no that's not that's not a show I would
watch on mushrooms I don't think it was
intense when they were starting hurting
people I was like boy oh my God these
people are [__] Devils I felt like
the Demons of the people have did you go
did you watch that episode did you watch
yourself on that episode watch the whole
thing we watched every episode that was
it was fun I could see where I was like
oh God amazing you're gone could you see
in your face yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
was over in his own little world yeah a
little bit Yeah 100 yeah I can see it
all yeah it was it was pretty amazing
Jake really steered the ship which was
nice
yeah everybody yeah so tall
I will tell you watching it back was
fascinating because you could be like at
different points you could be like oh
he's [__] up oh I'm [__] up oh he's
[__] I always say he's I'm like that's
used yeah yeah
that's me I loved it the last episode
was fun but when I went home oh man it
was a rough we were both like that
wasn't for you
it was it was a challenge even when I
finally got home and I only took a
fraction of the [__] yeah it wasn't
yeah but still he was like what do you
mean
you're on Drew this [__] eyes
then we had to do some ad reads it was
who it was and then we left
but that's what happened last time you
were here I went and performed yeah
which is pretty crazy while you were on
stage with [__] on your back yeah
[Laughter]
no this time I had to go poop and I was
like I'm not risking it I just I
couldn't risk [__] on my pants again
because
yeah and here's the deal like because
here's the real reason I couldn't risk
it I didn't quite know how it happened
the first time
so it's not like I could go in and do
something to prevent it from happening
are you sure it was [__] dude
I was in the hotel room by myself don't
you think I sniffed it oh of course I
did I I was like is that chocolate nope
what if it was somebody else's [__] you
said and put in a straight line I know
that was the mystery you got it goes
this way you sat down you slipped there
was a nugget on the seat he says by the
way here's a nugget of [__] I had
if I
if I I thought of that if I had sat in
it it wouldn't have been that far up
okay on my right because it was right
below the waistband detective it
happened when you pulled your pants back
up around you but why this way I don't
you know what I mean that is what in not
this much oh a lot this much I know it's
gonna be good and then 15 years from now
we find out Jake did it to him just like
the porn [__]
15 years I [__] on your pants
that would be so fun
that is like right in line with that
type of [__] that they do if he was like
I go I can't believe that [__] myself at
The Comedy Store you know he was like no
you left the house with it on
I've been like why didn't he like I put
it on there before he left the house is
that your [__] yeah that's right dude if
he [__] if he had [__]
[__] like [__] yeah [__]
you do to yourself
like that's what [__] it is okay right
that feels personal yeah I [__]
myself yeah okay you're right yeah you
know what I mean that feels like that
does feel right shot feels plural like
they shot okay yeah
grown grown grown this is a great
podcast talking about [__] this is
[__] in a [__] I love these
conversations yeah but we still haven't
gotten to the bottom yeah no I think we
have
that's but I did um
I mean it happens but it happens
it does happen can we address the
situation real quick what's up guys just
taking a break from this ridiculous
episode to talk about one of our
longtime sponsors and this is manscaped
before we even get started let me give
you this information to take advantage
of this deal right now right now if you
go to manscape.com forward slash Yola or
you'd call Yola at checkout you're gonna
get 20 off of everything and anything
you buy plus free shipping and they have
the perfect package 4.0 luxury and
grooming kit the perfect package is a
play on Dick joke manscaped is right on
point but also they are the leading
company on Earth for male grooming and
male grooming kits eight million
customers and 16 million balls cannot be
wrong when it comes to manscaped
lawnmower 4.0 you already know it's skin
safe uh Wireless chargeable has a light
on it's waterproof that comes in the
perfect package 4.0 along with crop
preserver anti-chafing ball deodorant
crop reviver bald toner disposable
shaving mats or the magic mat plus two
free gifts is the travel bag and the
boxers this all comes in the perfect
package 4.0 go ahead and go to
manscape.com right now forward slash
YOLO or like I said use code Yola at
checkout get anything or everything I
just said for twenty percent off and
free shipping thank you guys so much for
supporting the companies that support us
back to this ridiculous episode
I came straight from a rapper party
that's why I'm dressed like I have this
jacket on or else you know I would have
just a regular sweater it's just kind of
odd like hey what's up guys it's [__]
all dressed up and [__] I came straight
from party [__]
continue yeah okay I was like okay we
gotta dress this yeah a shiny Ninja
Turtles right here all right I'm used to
seeing you in that on your profile
picture it looks like
that red watermelon gum Bubblicious
same color scheme yeah it should have
said it was tight I had parachute pants
with that color scheme mmm bomb [__]
yeah dude bomb I also had black ones
that had like a bright red when you
opened it up oh sick you don't think I
was doing the moonwalk in those can you
do the moonwalk still uh in my socks how
do you do it
um are you pushing while this food's
moving back so it's like an illusion I
don't know it's hard for me to describe
because like it's
first of all have you ever said that's
the only thing I can even like I would
give myself a three out of ten my
running man just looks like a dude who's
running my running man like I don't
quite understand the concept of jogging
in place yeah okay hold on
oh we're gonna do it let me see it let's
see it you ready for the running man I
am
The Running Man is something like
what the [__] you not mention no dude I
have to get ready this I think this
where the hands go right it's like a
sparring stance here
[Laughter]
and everybody okay here we go let's see
oh handlebars
okay ready all right
all right there's nothing with a washer
is off balance
how is that
I gotta be honest
I'm pretty sure that wasn't it let's see
past Running Man we've ever had on the
show that's true I'm sure yeah listen at
this table that is the best possible
running man running man number rating
compared to your moonwalk uh
the
the uh that's probably a point four
point four oh okay so your moonwalk is
tight it's I mean anywhere is up from
there
do you know what I mean yeah so like by
showing you that one first whatever I
show you next you'll be like yeah the
moonwalk's a lot easier that's more
that's a high difficulty level to get
everything [__] going away yeah or
even one yeah yeah
or even one yeah damn that's kind of
Awesome
can we touch on something real quick
what you're out there slanging shrooms
[__] up your pants slanging shrooms
that's mean cell Marty Josh does not
sell shrooms on tour people know what we
mean
I don't think they do that no okay all
right consumer true yeah there we go
your wife has a top 10 Netflix movie
streaming right now [__] in
effect for the past two weeks which is
unheard of
congratulations
it's been in the top ten
um she wrote and directed the movie
it's called Forever my girl it's like a
real
nice funny great story Love Story it's
if you like
um I wouldn't even call it a romantic
comedy but it was uh she adapted it from
a book and
um there's a popular book but she
absolutely crushed it and she and like I
said to write and direct it that's crazy
and
um
like
it wasn't featured on Netflix we didn't
see any promos for it and it for it to
be it started 10 and then it went like
the seven then to five for a minute all
on its own merits it's just a good story
and you can watch it with your family
and so it's super cool
super cool what I like about the story
is that you said it was completed five
years ago
so yeah has she been pitching it this
whole time like how did the timing come
about where it's like she's had this but
now bam it's a hundred percent I guess
either up to them I don't know or if the
was pre-made or whatever
but this is when they decided to release
it and I know she's yeah dude but
pretty crazy
to have it just Word of Mouth
because and I asked Jacob because I'm
not on there that much I go how long do
things usually stay in these top ten I
don't think very long yeah if you chart
at all I worked on a show for Netflix
last year and it's like the fact that it
even hit the charts it was like huge
huge win yeah in any country let alone
like the United States like yeah you're
talking about the smallest 0.01
percentile of shows that go up on
Netflix and end up charting like that
that's been here for two weeks is huge
yes and it really is she's so talented
dude and so this story is super she's a
great writer and she sees things
beautifully like our wherever we've ever
lived
she's like she asked me one question
about furniture I'm like you you did
this you don't want my opinion you're so
[__] but she sees everything as a
movie
and so like like this is her new
clothing line that drops win uh this
comes out Monday
I think maybe
today
really
it's either today or Thursday okay so by
the way sometime this week the beautiful
Earth
yeah the beautiful areas how can
everybody go check it out yeah dude it
is and her clothing is all sustainable
and it's all what's the website uh I'm
assuming the beautiful earthquake
uh but you can follow her on Instagram
right now for sure
it's the beautiful Earth and um I'm sure
her website's up there I'm assuming this
is what it is babe I'm trying to
remember I'm doing my best yeah it's
sustainable yeah but I'll tell you
something so I like wearing hats
the two things the beanies she have has
I gotta tell you it's the only beanie
I've ever worn that has an itch in my
forehead it's made out of human hair
yeah dude it's made out of your own skin
it doesn't issue so it just Blends right
in yeah
no it's so [__] comfortable and then
um same with the trucker hats they don't
dig into my forehead or anything like
that so if you're into hats this is a
good spot also good [__] yeah yeah
there's got a lot of [__] popping at
once
how has she reacting to it like
like I would imagine the Journey of
making this movie is so much time going
by and then it come out and they're
charting like what's it been like to be
around her what's her vibing like it's
it takes everything
in stride
because she's been in this business like
that okay
she's super excited she's really proud
of herself but you know and we do check
every day yeah just you know of course
but
she's a really level-headed person so
this stuff doesn't affect her it's one
of the good things from being in the
business for so long like you understand
that
you know it's that's just work yeah
true I've I've seen the people in the
higher ups where it's it is just normal
to them yeah it well no that's not it
like but like
she doesn't want to be like Oh I'm a
superstar it's not like she's got nine
nine thousand offers if she was like oh
this is gonna lead to something you
that's you can't take yourself on that
ride yeah yeah that's what I mean she's
still grinding basically she is she's
like I can't take myself on the ride of
what this is all of a sudden I'm a star
there's that's not what's happening you
know what I mean so that's why she's
super excited and proud of herself
but it hasn't really changed her
I'm sure yeah does that make sense I can
do I I can do so if I did this I could
do so much that's how I would be
thinking yeah but I I think she
knows what she can do yeah
just have this one happened to be big
yeah I think I'm still going to work
she's still and she's still she's
that was a great movie and she's
probably more talented now than she was
then you know what I mean I'm sure she
was five years ago yeah yeah yeah yeah
she's a [__] brilliant artist yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then yours mushrooms
the other side of the house yes yeah
yeah yeah
it's funny sometimes she'll have me read
one of her scripts and I'm like do you
need more dick jokes like what are you
handing this to me for
I said no just need someone to read yeah
yeah just read them on my okay when [__]
I get it I'm always like this is the
best thing I've ever read so I mean
could use more dick jokes but there's
another dick in there when she's crying
yeah
you know it would work right here a fart
joke you should on the past yeah [__] on
the pants do you have room for an
awkwardly pal on Buff man in your movie
break dances
that's one of my favorite things
anyone's ever said to me an awkwardly
ripped and pale 50 year old man didn't
we establish that as his title for his
next yeah it was on it was on your uh
show and one of your judges said it
right yeah
God damn that was [__] kind of funny
it's like I'm looking at some awkward I
think he called me first thing he said
was vampires yeah yeah I think so thank
you sir yeah now I noticed uh on your
YouTube channel that you did something
that not a lot of comedians do which is
just post hours worth of material
without it being like a special just I'm
a comedian I'm out on the road here's an
hour yeah of just straight up weird
crazy stories yeah
now from that from all that and all
every time on the road but mainly from
that video is there anything that really
stand out
yeah uh well my favorite one ever is up
on the
up on the page but my favorite one ever
was the first one that really ever
happened to me
I was in
um Connecticut on stage at a casino
and um I'm doing my jokes and um
from like over my left shoulder I just
hear oh
and I look and then there's a woman and
you know those giant margarita glasses
were supposed to have five or six people
drinking at it just her straw
and it was empty she drank the whole the
whole thing
and uh I look at her and she's like this
and just mouthful
and uh she reaches over she grabs the
glass
she slowly brings it to her she's
looking at me the whole time I'm just
telling a joke you're on stage I'm doing
my joke dude
and she just goes like this
and just drops it out of her mouth she
just baby birds it right into the cup
right and I was like and I'm looking
around nobody nope nobody noticed
and she just pushed the glass away from
her
and I was like
and he my attitude was this clearly she
wanted to be there right so I'm not
gonna throw her out no she's working
hard to throw up silence yeah dude she's
working hard who am I just went yeah
right I just kind of was like looked
around and
so maybe like 12 minutes later this is
all on my YouTube page I happen to be
filming that night
she
I just hear again
she grabs the glass same thing still
still nobody dude still nobody noticing
and it's like strangers sit at your
table in a club no no no okay okay so it
was just her and three of her friends
she she wasn't alone no it was her and
three of her friends she brings a cup
she baby birds it again right
and I see one of her friends leaning
over to her
and I think I'm gonna hear her go you
know hey
let's get you out of here
and she leans over and then just see her
go
get your [__] together
that's it
what age group were these women
that's gonna be a big [__] like get your
[__] together if you're young is funnier
if they're old it's like you know what
still funny yes super funny
they were they were older not older they
were like probably I bet you 38 39 for
it okay
um nurses
because they reached out to me after oh
we've they came to another show it was
so much same lady yeah but she didn't
throw up this time but so the she one
more time gosh she throws up in the cup
three times this is the third time the
same cup same overflowing with [__]
people here's the thing
she I had to throw her out after the
third throw up because she filled up the
cup and I was like wow
I can't have you throw up again because
now it's a mess and so so they they
walked her out but it was maybe the
weirdest because she was so calm about
it and nobody I stopped the show
afterwards
and I go no none of you none of you saw
that and they were like what I go that
woman just threw up three times in her
cup and they were like what I'm like
you're sitting right next to her like if
I were to sneeze or cough a little bit
too much I'd get the [__] up and get out
of there like I'd be so much 100 that
would cough a little too loud but I'll
go the bathroom this lady was such a
trooper are you kidding me right now I
love it she she was a hundred percent
like
I'm I'm gonna stick around if you're
here for the show if you're gonna let me
yeah and her friends were pretty calm
about it but as soon as I said
uh you guys you gotta get her out of
here they were up so quickly they knew
it was coming at some point they had
already prepped you know they had
already packed their purses ruins
another night was there any part of you
that wanted to puke when you saw that no
I was I in my head I was laughing too
hard
I it was such a crazy weird secret that
she and I were keeping
just like
um how long can she keep throwing up
when it's just me and her noticing it
was a weird you know it was just
on like I like [__] like that yeah I
like it you like weird [__] I like it a
lot I know I know that so that no you do
I was just like this is so interesting
the one that nobody knows it's like a
sociology experiment ah it was so crazy
speaking of that what's the weirdest
[__] you've seen in Vegas so far
oh Mom we need to hear it wow dude I
live a pretty quiet life there when
you're when you're out and about you
must have seen something you had a
conversation with some woman that was a
Nazi or something crazy well I can't
tell you last night here see
last night
here right
I uh
I'm getting this guy's Uber
and
um
he goes Joshua I go yeah and he's okay
he goes going to the whatever and I go
yep
and we take off this in his Tesla like
and I'm like hey dude I'm in because I'm
a mushrooms I'm in no shape to be going
this fast I I hate
no you had to say something yeah I had
no need to drive this quick dude I'm
[__] chilling yeah I go I'm I'm good
I'm good I'm in no rush and you guys I
just want to make sure you know I can
get you to where you need to go
and I was like hmm
trying to proposing something to me and
I was like I don't know what that means
you know what I mean like that's why I
called you yeah
I go just slow down honestly I'm good he
goes okay if that's what you want I'm
listening to you and he slows down
and um he's being oddly
professional
uh like
to like is this the mushrooms talking no
maybe
he was just too polite and get your hand
no dude not polite
professional
and wanted me to know
not only he was good at his job he's a
chauffeur that type of professional yeah
like that he this dude he was in control
and knew everything that was happening
and like right caught exuding crazy
confidence
is that okay
and we pull up to the hotel
and I go to get out and he locks the
door
and he goes you can't leave until I ask
you something and I was like
just unlock the door
and he was like let me just ask you one
question
and I go yeah he goes
you need some security
you need private security
and I uh what do you mean he goes to
walk you around every day you need
security I go dude I don't live here he
goes
since when
and I was like what does that mean what
do you mean since when he goes since
when don't you live here
and I was like well I gotta go brother
and I unlocked the door and I get out
and he
he drove away anybody screamed out the
window no offense and I was like that
doesn't make sense
[Music]
might be a private security guard and he
thought I lived in L.A still I guess but
yeah but why would you be dropping me
off at a hotel if I lived in it
you should not be a security guard dude
you're dropping me off at a hotel I
called an Uber yeah yeah if I lived here
I'd be driving myself to my house
yeah do you think he was a fan of yours
is very awkward
yo dude that is right yeah you know you
need some security you're Josh hole that
made it awkward since when made it seem
like I know you live I know you live
yeah
well it was he made it awkward in how he
was presenting himself because he was no
offense he wanted yeah dude and I was
like that's not that's not the right
thing it doesn't make sense yeah
I mean I knew what he meant yeah yeah
that wasn't the right language yeah yeah
for him to be like pitching you on
personal security like it's almost like
threatening you in a passive-aggressive
way yeah but also like being bad at
security like you're not you're not
being alert and I need my security guard
alert if you think I live in Los Angeles
and ubered to a hotel from The Comedy
Store you're off yeah dude if you were
gonna be hired you fired now
yeah yeah holy [__] failed them amazing
yeah yeah I love that that was yeah
I it's interesting like if you're gonna
be a driver
I think what's your first instinct if
you're the if you're a driver
do you speak before some to somebody
else before they speak to you yeah hey
how you doing yeah just the basics just
that one right the basic one that's
right hey good morning I think you do
that and the other person goes good
thanks you and we're never good and then
after that after that you go if you need
anything you let me know done because
it's the open-ended question of like hey
I'm friendly enough to you can just ask
me stuff also I'll shut the [__] up and
let you keep talking that's the best one
I've ever heard I think you that is the
exact yeah that's amazing because it is
a task to sit there and hold the
conversation with a stranger in their
car the whole ride if you don't want to
oh I I oh man right sometimes
Uber to stop talking she's like you know
what I used to deliver pizzas
I can't slide to be in the car all day
but also I'm one guy for 38 minutes yeah
and he kept saying you know Thomas
he was formed but he kept talking like
you know
and he would look at the thing Thomas
you forget my name and looking down at
the name on the thing Thomas he would
pause hello you can't ask me about his
son all he wants to do his game
but he also wants to send to a truck
driving school
for his son my whole family to truck
drivers I told him how to get his CDLs
and all this gym yeah you do this also
you do this have someone just gets in
the middle and every time and then uh oh
sorry to put you on blast
from the do knows podcast I got as soon
as I got him like hell yeah I like being
around I think some of the funnest
people are
dudes that are slightly flamboyant gay
dudes but they're also like
I'm a guy too my guy at first he didn't
know what kind of person that was he was
like yeah I'm sorry I mean how's your
day going he's like just fight with my
partner right now like oh man I'm sorry
that sucks yeah she uh she moved in she
moved in and it's not going well and I
and I told him like well if you don't
want to live here move back with your
dad and he's like him and him my
boyfriend and he kept looking at me like
like bro it's fine continue yeah for 40
minutes he was showing me his man's
location on the phone where he was at to
give me what I think of what he's doing
talking about his ex
went through the whole Spiel for 40
minutes gave me the breakdown gave me it
was about him his location being
different his old boyfriend was rich as
hell and he thinks he's at the movies
with him and he's lying they talk about
his mom and at the end halfway through
goes I'll shut up if you want to shut up
no it's fine man the whole time I
switched you dude I was just giving him
real advice and at the end goes thank
you I'm like so tonight what you're
gonna do and he's like could you just
help me and I'm like I stayed like five
minutes outside the warehouse I'm like
this is what you're gonna do you're
gonna walk in you're gonna tell him this
this and this and depending if he says
this this or this is your answer
and he was all Juiced I was I'm [__]
going home right now and he [__]
drove off all hyped up he wrote um his
Essence and the like how he was was oh
geez wife Mindy they're saying like well
[__] you
exactly how it was but every Uber I'm in
turns into a
an amazing conversation I I my favorite
one actually maybe ever and maybe it's
just because of favorite because I it's
a little dark to it was a dude to pick
me up in St Louis and
um
he was arranged by the club so they he
knew as a comic
and I get in and he's like hey I go hey
and he goes you a comedian there you go
man that's right
anyways uh and he holds up a book
you know it was a it was a dirty joke
word not politically collect correct
joke book
right
and um
the first question he asked me he looks
in the rearview mirror and he goes how
you feel about Jews
and I'm Jewish right I go whatever
I'm good with them without him doesn't
matter he goes I got a bunch of good Jew
jokes in here I'm like cool let's hear a
couple and so he there he threw a couple
out there they were pretty they were
okay
their prayer okay they were okay listen
I I people say to me all the time if you
should people tell Holocaust jokes if
they're funny they're funny if they're
funny
yeah this is what I'm saying like
nothing's off limits I don't think so
unless it's just like that wasn't funny
that was me this is what we're coming
from I think people well look man I mean
you go oh [__] that was [__] up that's
like okay that was pretty funny yeah if
you don't chuckle slightly and you go
dude you just call me a [__] that's all
you did yeah
you hit me like that's the thing like if
it's fun I had a guy in in Myrtle Beach
say to me he waited in the meet and
greet line to say to me his friends were
behind him
and he goes uh
you know what that was a real funny show
and I said thanks man he goes look over
at his friends and he goes I don't
usually think you people are that funny
and I go
you people I go what
and he starts to laugh and he looks at
his friends again and he goes you know
kites with a t got me a kite with a t
and I said what
he was you know kites
oh yeah he goes yeah you people I was
like so he was calling me a kite I was
like yeah dude yeah we're usually not
that funny kites yeah they're not
because you know what the yes yeah I got
you I got you I got you
and so the guy next to me was like did
that bother you I'm like did he call me
a kite no because that means
either all of his friends think that's
the right word
which is funny which is funny or they
know he was saying the wrong word and
that's why they sent him up
also funny so you know what I'm saying
think of that option both funny to me
there's no other explanation could you
make a bigger [__] out of yourself it
was so [__] think of option two it's
so but but the point being like I could
have chosen to be offended because I
know what he was trying to say right
yeah but it was so funny that he thought
it was kite
it just was incredible it blew my mind
that's why I had him say it again just
to make sure I was like I gotta hear
that again okay are you [__] with me
yeah yeah
it was like what exactly did you say
again kite got it yeah I love it
yeah I like I like seeing races make
mistakes there's a lot of that on
Twitter it's so much fun I love when
they misspell bumper stickers and [__]
you ever see those in the South oh man
Mario you should find some of those one
day
people make their own bummer Series in
the South but they spell [__] wrong oh
the time it's great
it's just like make their own what do
you mean like McDonald's
political [__] now they like print it
out and cut it out and stick it on the
window oh I gotcha it's great I love it
all right so you're in Vegas by the way
if someone gave me right now
no directions no
anything just said I'm gonna give you
a million tries
to make a bumper sticker
I don't even know it's gonna look like
the cartoon guy you always draw yes yeah
I don't think I could get the sticky
part down like do you know what I'm
saying like if someone was like cut a
tree yeah I'm gonna give you a million
tries oh you really gotta like invent a
yeah yeah yeah
if they're a million shots I don't even
I don't think I could do it I'll find
those trees that [__] up your windshield
below the sap oh those are good ones
boom done
but that's like you think of some of the
it seems like such a simple thing you
know what else but a lot of us don't
know how to do [__] Josh could you build
this table no how long would it take how
long would it take you to build would
this table be here so I could look at it
no no it's Gotta just come from the mind
oh dude like think of the bracket and
the thing that makes the leg go up in
and like because I always think how do
you bolt how do you put the screws or
the nails in the 2x4 into the top
there's not nails are long enough to go
all the way in you don't hit them at an
angle
here's what's crazy I don't even know
what you're talking about exactly
you were like how do you know I was like
stop it right there I don't know what
you're describing right now you're
talking about underneath the table
where the things go food
[Music]
and we're in the forest I'll be meat
mushrooms till we die yeah that's some
exposure and a trip would be there she's
like well I'm gonna hit your bodies I
guess trap built this table out of wood
pieces
incredible and then this
goes through the roof to metal brackets
up into the roof above it in the Attic
how did you know where the metal
brackets were do you have like a
no he put the middle brackets in there
huh oh you did yeah
no I'm out you always say like yo if it
was apocalypse I'd walk because I don't
know how to fix a car done so [__]
over get a horse find a [__] horse
because I'm not gonna fix a car I I
wouldn't know where to start although
College
did figure out no not really
I was gonna say I kind of figured out
how to change the tire but I wouldn't be
confident to do it oh I continue to Tire
just because my family's a truck driver
that made me stare at it I would I
wouldn't be confident to do it it's not
it's not as hard as you think but the
[__] that like it's a big responsibility
I call Trent all the time like yo this
breaker doesn't work he goes well you
have to run the wiring back and see if
it's connected like I'll move yeah I'll
move first yeah
if I had to like yo says detrimental I
just leave
I
guess the next person that lives here
will be dealing with this I know what
you mean 100 are you handy around the
house
it's comical how unhandy I am around the
house you like me I'm trash we just
completely renovated my house too so
it's really been brought to light how
useless I am oh do they yeah yeah yeah
yeah
when like Beth
because she has to have stuff done
around the house you know and um because
I I can't do it
and I always say to where I go can't you
can't you have the handyman come over
when I'm not there
you know what I mean
I mean it's just
sticks so it doesn't look like I'm just
a [__] dum-dum who doesn't know how
to put up a lights
the guy in his bag yeah yeah yeah
Crowley yeah when the handyman comes
over I'm like yo I'm I [__] try I
always say I'm [__] trash at this can
you fix this yeah because I just I'm
like this is exactly what the [__] is
going on I can't do this I'm not a
gardener I'm not a cleaner I'm not a
handyman there's a couple things
yeah I mean you can clean I can do
normal cleaning but then there's like
actual deep cleaning that like passes
harder yeah my clean isn't clean enough
for like my clean prisoner cell clean
like yo spotless I don't know why my
brain's like it feels better when the
shit's clean yeah I think I'm somewhere
in between there yeah my clean is
organized yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh [__] I'm sorry
um now one thing I've been seeing that's
a little bit off topic that I want to
remember I asked you about
hosting stripper auditions in Vegas
oh no
um
Josh is on stage with a guitar
oh no oh the male stripper stuff oh way
less cool I thought you were talking
about a show a pilot that I shot oh more
for
um what was the network that was
supposed to be for dudes
so it was a yeah that was my nickname in
high school
yeah so
so
[Laughter]
um
so uh what were you talking about [__]
for real because
males so first Spike TV
um
it was a show it was supposed to be
American Idol but for strippers
incredible and so we shot a pilot me
what was the guy
Jeff Beecher Jeff Beecher musher that is
uh he used to do something called
beecher's madhouse
um which then which was a big live show
in Vegas I think he had a show for a
minute here and the host was Carmen
Electra Carmen Electra when she was on
like scary movie getting her boob
stabbed that's right yeah that's right
the pilot was like listen it might have
been it was maybe the dumbest thing I've
ever done but
but
um I thought for Spike TV I mean it's of
course clearly
is gonna go yeah of course it didn't
right thank God why stripper audition
sounds hilarious no you know what sounds
like Flavor of Love it was I I recently
went back because I was looking at find
a whole stack of DVDs and it was it was
basically everything I had ever done I
was like
and so I sat down and I watched some of
it and I watched that
pilot it's the worst thing I've ever
seen in my life I'm so glad that did do
they have you uh open shirt talking no
no thank you
that would have been hilarious though
no because we were judges
so it was just like it was bad
production the how would you judge them
what was something that you would say to
a male stripper's performance I don't
know these were women okay
you would just you oh yeah that's a
little weird it was yeah it was T it was
like you had to keep it TV and I was
like the real positive dude
well I think just because your ass
doesn't look great that doesn't mean
that you can't shake your ass you know
what I'm saying like there's something
for everyone you would shake it yeah
and plants are inexpensive yeah they're
just always on the up
yeah it's so funny man how quickly
things changed it what you can and can't
do oh fast do you know what I mean yeah
hey baby like exactly
you if you pitch that show right now
people would be like are you out of your
[__] yeah and two male judges I was
thinking that as you were saying it
right yeah two male judges now I think
the way they've made it more woman
friendly is they had Carmen is the host
of course that was in the Howard Stern
era too where it was like normal it was
just really it
because you think on it now and you're
like oh you could never do that with two
dudes judging yeah women dancing yeah
that would
and and somebody pitched it and bought
it it's crazy and that I mean that
probably was how many years ago
probably awesome the editing and
production was better
the real world we shouted at the
Troubadour I think guaranteed boobs on
the real world people are gonna watch
what are they doing just blaring out the
boobs and stuff or were they like no I I
they kept bikinis oh kept bikinis yeah
I think that's what it was absolutely yo
you're eliminated because you know you
didn't clack your heels together louder
but like but like your booty clapping
wasn't [__] enough for us sorry
you're out of here I think I think once
you see I think the idea is like once
you see it and this is the first round
how many more rounds
and we were games how many eliminate can
you do how many more how many more
dances on the poll I think probably is
what they thought is like how many how
could we keep this interesting and you
really can't RuPaul's Drag Race has
found a way to keep it interesting but
what a great show great show love that
show it's a bunch of dudes going I can
walk where to do in these heels better
than everybody I'm like yo these ladies
are sick
just this is a great show
but anyway that is a great job it is and
this was a horrible show but look at
they're on season like 40. they won't
stop they're doing the same same games
over and over yeah but different people
I know before it makes it to be
different people too yeah but it's
there's no there's no fun to it I feel
the show was really just the I'm not
comparing strippers to Rupee yeah by the
way guys
and the strippers there was no games it
was just dancing oh
it's a real strip audition yeah it's
just it was just the party Oh I thought
it'd be like we live in the house you
got eliminated because you didn't pop as
many balloons as me on the game yeah I
know you know they do those stupid ass
shows there is no game and so like it
was like okay but like
oh that's a whole different game yeah
yeah yeah it was 100 yeah yeah yeah it
was 100 to post it when I first got to
LA
I did I I worked um
so there was a pilot for a game show and
uh there used to be a um
there used to be a uh
like a like a Playboy rip-off called
Perfect 10 magazine
and they and they pitched a perfect 10
game show
where Perfect 10 models just played
games
in their bikinis
right and I said I worked the crowd you
know how sometimes like if there's a
live studio audience in between takes
yes somebody will come out or whatever
no no not sure what like I'm basically
the hype man keeps the people that's
entertained right
so um
I worked to show where
they it was just dudes with boners
[Laughter]
in the crowd just boners boner dudes and
it was a small production so it was only
like 30 dudes so it's super awkward
it was like 30 boner dudes and that was
the crowd and I was like all right
everybody well I mean I'm sure you don't
give a [__] what I have to say right now
oh my God you took such a positive
you're gonna say some intellectualized
[__] no it's just a bunch of twos and
bumpers yeah and then waited so long in
the crowd yeah that's the show was about
to do yeah
oh
dude there was no it didn't matter what
I it's just like I've ever told you
there was a show that I did at a bikini
bar
and um
the
show did um
comic
girl kind of girl comic girl and the
night was called giggles and jiggles
incredible yeah but nobody wanted to see
us because they didn't I don't think I
advertised it that well oh
and it was hard it was hard sometimes
for the
mostly difficult for the female Comics
because when they came out
the guys in the audience weren't sure if
they were
you got to take their clothes off
honestly if you're a girl do you really
take that one I love the balls you can't
that's crazy I [__] love the balls
yeah it was yeah it was a long time ago
that's but I don't even want to go to
the grocery store sometimes with two
memo I'm a hot [__] leave me alone let
alone like yo I'm gonna go talk like I'm
not taking my oh no but but but look man
you if you a lot of women and the wind
the ones who took that gig
I'm sure knew what was coming
and I hope everyone that I saw just
kicked the audience right in the face do
you know what I mean nice I'm sure they
had I'm sure or they had seen the show
before and been like yeah
I know what I need to do I just imagine
someone like what the [__] like get off
me I'm trying to sing a song up here
[__] let's get in the forest come
from Jenny's naked that's what I imagine
yeah exactly
that's hilarious
I'm gonna be real high one other thing I
wanted to bring up yeah now uh Jake
notoriously came on here with his porno
Scandal and it was closed yeah well yeah
it unraveled here on the show and the
world found out about it now I saw you
guys posted another video regarding a
different kind of Scandal with Jacob
where you accidentally found his dick
pics
yes
I don't know if that happened yeah I
don't know if that's a scandal
it's it but it was something scandalous
I was just uh I was just flipping on my
iPad I bet yo he had put he had put his
[__] in the cloud and he had set my iPad
up to be the cloud place
I don't know how that works me neither
place I told him to set my iPad up and
he must have set it up as the cloud play
so when I clicked on pictures
that's not me yeah that's exactly it it
was it was the dick that wasn't mine
and I said out loud
that's not my dick
right what was the first thing that ran
to you
that's not my dick it was the first
thing I was like that's not my dick yeah
whose dick is that
yeah whose dick is that it's usually a
game you don't want to play you know in
your photo album
hey your stick is that that is not any
situation that's a [__] up yeah yeah
um so was he honest about it or did he
make you unravel it as a mystery as to
what happened well I
I
I had noticed the desk
you investigated behind the dick and I
was like
yeah I you know I built that was my desk
yeah I built that desk yeah that's Damon
Jacob's room first of all I was like why
did you send me a dick pic well I I
realized because I saw some of the
pictures I'm like these are pictures
from his phone and then uh I was love I
I turned to Beth because look man if I'm
gonna be grossed out she is too no and I
turned her back
I turned to Beth and I go oh I go hey
she goes yeah I go check this out she
goes oh what the [__] oh come on
come on
face look at his [__] face
so funny so funny does he know that yeah
so
I told her I'm gonna be grossed so how
did you tell him that this happened she
had a FaceTime him right there I know I
just went down
yeah he lived in the he lived in the
room down the hall oh
so I went down the hall and I was like
because he had lectured me about how you
get things on the cloud because I didn't
know I told him it's confusing
and um I go ahead tell me I like a lot
of works again
oh you're so stupid and I was like yeah
we'll see
I said uh
tell me how it works he goes you you
take a picture on your phone it goes to
your iPad I go okay what else he goes
mom takes a picture on her phone goes to
your iPad and go what else he goes I
take a picture on my phone oh no
and that was like yeah and he wanted to
see the iPad and I was like no
but yeah turns out he was taking dick
pics
could you imagine the [__] horror the
best part is you could technically write
down Jake sent me a dick pic a few times
and it was [__] weird exactly I'm
gonna use it on stage like you remember
you said it's not really how it happened
can I say exactly can I tell you
something
funny about that particular joke and
Jacob said this out loud before it was
the one that bothered him the most
because no because because
um
it was from beginning to end like if I
had finished the story beginning to end
true
nothing ad-libs no beginning to end that
story is in both your eyes is how it
happened yep that's how it happened and
uh so he hated that story the most and
so I didn't tell it for a long time
because oh this wasn't recent
no no no no no oh you're better way
worse for him yeah we he this was he was
in high school real embarrassment
cocky goes to your you don't use the
cloud yeah yes
through 16 15. that dude oh no yeah yeah
I wouldn't do it to him now
you know but he needed it then yeah yeah
the story changes now it's funnier yeah
yeah
yeah he went to the bathroom and just
sat there for a while I was like damn
you want to come by the room dude he I
tell you something so that story
bothered him right you want to know when
it changed
when it's it didn't bother him anymore
David Ortiz is his favorite baseball
player okay
and we've had the Privileges
hanging out with him some and the first
thing he said to Jacob is he said that
joke about the dick pics is my favorite
one oh
and he was like what he was like that's
my favorite story about you
and it changed Jacob's and Poppy shook
his hand and he was like entreated Jacob
was like he treated me like a real like
just a person
and he was that's his Idol right and so
Jacob was like I I should forget about
how I feel about those stories and think
about how people are receiving them and
he was like they're
they almost feel bad for me like that
they like me because of those stories
and I was like yeah dude you're not the
villain in that story I'm I am you're
the one that said hey look at this yeah
yeah
do you know what I mean totally you're
you're a dude who made of in today's day
and age probably a common mistake where
pictures
embarrassing [__] like that happens it
was a great lesson for him like he said
it really changed how I saw those
stories and how I thought about myself
it was a [__] great moment what are
the odds that his Idol would bring that
one back around for him it was amazing
it truly was super and I think one of
the best things that happened to him for
sure because when you when something
that you thought
was a negative is a positive
of course that is the best yeah do you
know what I mean totally and so it was
like almost instantly like a new
charge it was [__] fantastic so you
are you going on the road completely all
the time with Jake yeah wow that's so
cool man it's so much fun that's never
happened before right last time you guys
were talking about thanks you were doing
some shows I mean I think
uh Joe Coy and his son travel together I
don't know if Little Joe gets on stage
how old is he
um that's a great question he's not like
Chase no no no no no
yeah I want to say 16 or 17. oh so he's
pretty older I think so I don't think
he's graduated high school yet Jake's
the perfect age for the show oh my god
oh of course he can do this
with hair and by beer and talk on stage
like you're tall and like you just say
stuff too funny as [__] he's a perfect
combination of like
this guy's been [__] with me my whole
life you know exactly these guys just
[__] with me all night babysitter
that's right exactly if anyone's gonna
be up there it should be [__] you
yeah if you really think about it I
didn't think about when we first met you
when I first met him remember when you
facetimed me the first time I met him
he's like I'm upset
like I didn't think about like like he
was a kid still like yeah if you think
about like you're perfect for the stage
he is and we're like a really good
balance because if you look at the clips
we're sharing that I I don't care who
gets to laugh we're sharing the stage
and the energy yeah totally do you know
what I mean it's back and forth because
he has that kind of like
responsibility role to you like you did
to him too yes like he's looking after
you like it's like friends make a better
life decision Dad don't take your
insurance yeah yeah yeah sure yeah yeah
good balance I like that balance for
sure like there's a cartoon when I when
I basically if this was a cartoon
[__] man exactly when I do take too many
shrooms I'm telling you he's on the
lookout for time and like he keeps me
together sometimes I was describing me
and Rocco were talking about earlier
like like yeah he's like your boy to
make sure you can be you and do whatever
the [__] you want because he's gonna
make sure [__] gets done you are where
you need to be 100 everything's on the
up and up 100 and but just so everybody
knows and you can ask him that wasn't
like that his whole life like I think he
uh always knew he could come to me and
that like I loved him and but there was
no I was definitely parent before I was
yeah buddy I think the best way to get
to buddy is to parent first the time to
be your buddy is when he's grown he's 21
22 or whatever yeah yeah yeah also I saw
the uh question from a fan which brings
that up I don't know if you know the
name they said when was the first time
that you ever decided to get high with
Jake
Austin Prince thank you for the question
that I just remembered it because
everybody said like they always talk
about like you know they're doing
everything together they're talking
about these intimate ass stories or
getting embarrassed you he actively
smokes he he rolls rolling one of them
blood things I've heard you say it yeah
yeah yeah so like when's the first time
you're like you know what you're my
child
but I think it's okay if I smoked weed
around you oh do you want to hit this
here's what we do
like we smoke here sitting at the stable
right
he and I have never shared a joint oh
you've smoked your own yeah because like
you're a grown-up if you want to smoke
weed that is I'm not gonna say no but I
wouldn't sit here and do tequila shots
with him either
gotcha so for me look if you that's just
my thing if he wants to smoke weed he
can smoke weed I got no judgment I just
feel it's for me it's not for me and I
know a lot of people are every time I
say that they're a little surprised I
just I don't know why it's not it's not
something that I want to do hmm right
but I will tell you this I would love to
do shrooms with them
does he does he not do them he does but
he's like no [__] right oh damn
that's interesting yeah yeah he was like
that's the one I don't want to do with
you
yeah it's interesting I want to do it
because I think it's a I would do it
with any of my kids I think it's a great
bonding experience
do you know what I mean yeah be a great
[__] video
yeah but yeah
but but
um I think it'd be great bonding do you
always do like do you always do shrooms
with a task or do you just do it around
the house
well okay I'm gonna tell you guys a
story did I tell you the story
okay I had been shrooming a lot but I
wasn't
did I tell you about my night in the
Austin Hotel
oh my [__] God I don't know okay
I want to start if I need to stop you
tell me
so I land in Austin and on
the way to the hotel I'm in my rental
car
I just feel this rage
I mean
rage
I'm for what punching the roof of my
rental car
when I get out of the rental car am I
kicking my door because I'm mad
everything is making me so mad
I go inside I kind of settle down you
know what I mean relax a little bit I'm
like I need to just chill
I
am laying in bed and
um
I just feel like
I feel weird
that's all I can say I'm watching TV I
feel weird
and I just say I don't know why I say
this this was not my vibe at all I just
say hey
if there's
if there's something in me or on me
I don't want it
right just in case
this I was at that point feeling that
kind of weird like not me
and it felt like something just like
kind of held on to me and I was like hmm
so I said one more time I go hey
if you're if there's something on me
you're in me I don't want any part of it
ready
and I start to feel like dude
I'm having like a fight with something
inside of me I end up I'm outside the
covers shirt off
pushing my arm like I'm trying to
physically push something out of me on
both arms just I feeling like I'm
fighting something down
through my fingertips
and every time I felt full I would flick
my fingers and I feel a little more
scooch back up and I push both arms
right
and um
this was the [__] craziest part and
I'm not somebody who believes in this
stuff you just felt that you needed to
do that I look at the mirror you know
like in those horror movies when it
looks like something's traveling through
now I don't know if this is made up in
my brain because this is what I felt
like I must have been experiencing
but like I know that's what I saw when I
looked in the mirror and I started to
freak the [__] out and I'm screaming
get the [__] out of me
screaming because I it felt like there
was just something in me and I finally
flick enough where I I'm exhausted guys
I've been wrestling with something
and I fall back in the bed and I go to
sleep
but the room still felt kind of yucky
maybe I don't know however long I shot
up because it felt like something jumped
back on me
and I did that little wrestling match
for like
I don't know 10 more minutes and that
time
it felt like the air was completed the
second time I got it out it felt like
the air was completely clear there was
like a Stillness in the room it was the
weirdest [__] there at one point
I had forgotten that I had ordered pizza
and so
there's such a cop still serious story
and I imagine a guy going yeah and I
just here I'm gonna leave it at the door
I know because I was screaming get the
[__] out of me
[Laughter]
don't worry about the tip I'm Gonna
Leave it right here yeah
so yeah dude [__] craziest
thing in like I made a video recording
of myself that night
just to be like any drugs present were
you on mushrooms no this is what I'm
saying I had you were just pissed off
after you got the flight and got your
rental I had been
um
I had been taking a bunch but not that
day right and I had never heard of like
a residual do you feel when it started
it when you started getting that feeling
of being pissed was it in the airport
yeah just in the airport right and so
like I've had two explanations given to
me
one people who travel a lot if you
believe in this stuff just pick up other
energies when you walk by out of the
place yeah yeah okay that's what I was
thinking yeah and and I I actually
believe that yeah because I believe
energy is it travels and all that [__]
right
and another person said you know people
who because he asked me he goes how'd
you feel afterwards the next day
and I was like I felt
light I felt I said I don't know how
else to say it I felt cleansed and he
said um
so a lot of people who suffer from like
trauma that they don't remember
they're that's manifest that way it's
the only way your body can try to get
out of it to get it out of you
and I was like huh
and he was like because you feel better
today oh yeah I feel better but part of
that is because I thought I had a demon
in me last night so that makes me feel
way better today do you know what I mean
he goes yeah but he said that has
happened to a friend of mine before
so what a crazy
it was a crazy night we physically are
feeling something inside in your arms
light for real fighting with it like
fighting pushing it down flicking get
the [__] out of me it was a bananas
night and I woke up the next day
and
this is why this is what got me you know
waking up the next day
my instinct if you had said if that
happened to you would you have been
scared woken up scared I'd have been
like yeah imagine I'd have woken up
frightened but I woke up feeling like
chill
everything was okay it was it was a
[__] bananas but to only feel that
way for
what was it three hours max four hours
and to get it at the airport like that
it was so crazy it was so crazy I wish
there had been mushrooms involved
because then I could be a lot of
explanation yeah weird vibration yeah
yeah yeah then again why can't you catch
a weird vibration without mushrooms
motion just makes you realize that it's
that probably you think people who do
mushrooms are more susceptible to
picking those up for the residual days
after like the days after yes because
you ever feel off that wild mushroom
trip you come out the next day late
I feel different yeah it's like
structuring my brain different also the
best thing about this whole story you
just told is one day we're gonna get
this guys like you always deliver pizza
one time it said Joshua I don't know if
it was Josh Wolf the comedian but I was
excited this [__] and I just heard
somebody having like sex rough rough sex
horrible sex it sounded like it wasn't
wanted it sounded like him who was
screaming yeah he kind of sounded like
him yeah that's it that's one day we're
gonna get a clip on Tick Tock about that
what he must have been thinking walking
up because you know he's looking at the
numbers thinking to himself I hope
that's not my room
I hope that's not oh [__] I used to
deliver pizza yeah so I remember
thinking like I hope everybody's okay
here yeah yeah especially at hotels oh
worse than hotels I'm always doing this
yeah waiting for someone to come out
another room and Robbie the worst
delivering them at the hotels yeah we
still have pizzas at hotels the scariest
yeah enclosed hallway
don't know where I'm at yeah so demons
was that recently that was
like honestly
I don't remember eight months ago maybe
something like that but it was pretty
interesting that's wild man yeah it was
pretty intense and with no drugs
involved that's the one
I like I said even if I had been like
maybe an edible would but did it make
you question the way you think about
like uh yes everything yeah yeah yes
everything yeah because both of those
explanations
make sense to me
the as possibilities right as something
that oh yeah I guess that does make
sense that that could happen to somebody
so that so if that happened to you and
you experience something you're gonna go
to your grave think I don't know what
the [__] it was but I know what I failed
yes so you're opening you're open-minded
and what do you think about all this
alien [__] going on
yeah especially since you're in Vegas
yeah
I am
because one of the things that have has
always made me wonder why with all the
cell phones and all the cameras don't we
have
more video right but now
it seems like we do people just be more
open to I think I
want man I I um
I the only reason I was ever
skeptical
was because I never thought we were the
only people in the universe so that's
there's billions of galaxies too like
who knows how advanced right but I like
how we always just assumed that
everybody was that much smarter than us
that they had figured out how to get
here and we can't even figure out you
know what I mean and so I was always
like and then why would they assume why
would they hide in corn fields yeah it
seems like the wrong why be so petty and
cryptic with your [__] Petty and
cryptic he says yeah also one
possibility is what if they're stuck
here
well here's the thing I don't I'm not in
on the lizard people I don't think I'm
just saying like what if they live here
like yo we're trying to fly out of here
too our spacers don't go far
yo dude fly around you catch us with a
crash okay [__] crash you ever seen
District nine I should talk crazy it's
IET I saw E.T also that was crazy oh my
somebody
the other day had the unpopular opinion
that E.T was stupid
I don't think he was you know what don't
you dare right what like the movie as a
whole was stupid yeah oh no I thought
you meant like E.T the alien was kind of
dumb no like they did they didn't leave
his ass here he barely make some [__] to
get home yeah yeah so Hulk could make
but he could fly a bike he was
incredible yeah he's amazing yeah but
no it's a creep oh yeah come on man that
holds up for sure great I just watched
them play the other day I I was saying
this the other day
um I I had a chance you know who Sean
Aston is the actor oh
so I get to ask him you know because he
was in three movies oh you were
interviewing him no we were doing a a
charity golf this was years ago charity
golf event and I said to him dude you've
been in like most people get one if they
get a chance at all to be in one movie
that's stuck in Americana
year year and you've got Lord of the
Rings all of them Rudy and Goonies God
damn oh he's Rudy he's Rudy oh wow and
stranger things now yeah stranger things
but I asked him he didn't get eaten from
that I said um which one do people ask
you about the most
I said I'm so curious because there's
like they're all
iconic I quote him often right and which
one it's a hard time down here up there
it's their time yeah I usually say when
I'm taking dabs just to say stupid [__]
yeah uh but he says Goonies
because
people show their kids Goonies it'll
never not it'll for it's like a fairy
tale that people talk down to their kids
through centuries my grandma told the
story because The Goonies is never gonna
die it's gonna keep going I think so
because yeah
[__] gotta get that on here that that
because like that story is always good
do you you have to remember do you
remember the real extended version of
The Goonies before they cut it for TV
at the end well I saw it in the theaters
then you saw it when it came out yeah
and you saw the real version when the
giant squid tried to kill them
um do you remember they're getting to to
uh Willy's pirate ship and a giant squid
tries to eat them
I I I don't think so no I don't I don't
think I remember help me you do yeah
that's what happens before they start
finding all his gold they're getting
onto the ship in a big ass squid tries
to eat them that's amazing and then they
had to fight it off hey it's a [__]
check the archives it's pretty crazy
I don't know for time
maybe they did you mean a TV TV maybe
maybe they wanted it to be was it scary
I don't know it was a little bit I was
also four yeah yeah yo Sean aston's been
so many
caught like so many classic American
hits
you're in Lord of the Rings nerd he's
your everything too you love him I'm not
a big Lord of the Rings guy but I'm a
big Goonies guy and Rudy are you not a
lord do you not are you not a Sci-Fi
dude no I like Lord of the Rings it's
cool yeah I'm not gonna ever just go
watch them all again I when we flew to
Australia I watched uh all in a row
isn't it like a 15 hour flight yeah dude
when I when I was like well we got to be
landing didn't they film it there too uh
they filmed it in New Zealand New
Zealand okay
you know I gotta get the lay of the land
yeah
I'm walking through [__] yeah yeah I
just want to get accustomed to how
everybody does things there yeah yeah
how they greet each other everything
like that 16-hour flight completely
unbearable or what was how are you
feeling by the end of that
so
we did thank you we did
um
the
the way out here's what I hate I was
like dude I'm gonna get us the Vegas or
the Los Angeles to Sydney business class
and then we'll fly
um whatever economy from Sydney to the
other side of Australia but I'd rather
do that than a little better on each
plane let's take let's sleep and eat and
on the first ride right
so the they booked and they booked me on
the Australian
what was it called oh my God
it it's like what's
it's hoping to be Spirit oh
yeah
yo dude
it was I had a roof oh it man I'm five
11.
my knees were like this jacob
oh [__] Jacob sideways yeah by the
way okay and so
um you thought you were getting a pod oh
yeah yeah I was like it's just a little
bit of a downgrade
sonogram crunched into a little seat it
was crazy
it was and by the way no plugs no
strings no no plugs
no screens
just your thoughts so so like you could
for those of us who might not have known
on this five hour flight we weren't
gonna have I have another one for you
too already
we were gonna have a uh you want another
one yeah
We're not gonna have like another uh
bite to eat or
a chance to move our bodies
but like it was pretty rough sauce 16
hours no that was the good flight oh oh
okay oh so from to the other side of the
Australia is the one you guys got yeah
yeah
yeah I mean it was like
you know when you were taken off it was
like the pilot was like well good luck
[Laughter]
what did you think of Australia loved it
how's the weed
um do you remember I was taking a break
at the time remember I told you it was
perfect timing yeah
yeah sorry for nothing yeah yeah it was
actually a really good
we did go to this place in Melbourne and
these people
made us these muffins that I did have to
try
but
so then they smelled
so good I can't so good they were like
yeah weed muffins but they were like
like a crumble cake like a cinnamon
crumble that's that coffee cake um yeah
the whole [__] pan okay so these me
too it might be my favorite snack so I'm
like well I gotta have some of this
because it smells legit like real good
smells legit real good I loved it yeah
so I'm like okay I'm just gonna have a
little bit
as I'm watching staff members eat whole
muffins
I'm like I'm gonna check to see if I
these people are at work staff
members who are eating the muffins
because after the show there's somebody
brought it from the audience
and um
staff members and and some guys are at
the show just start eating the muffins
and uh
I I go I wonder does this say anything
in here
how many milligrams these are
right
and I'm looking I'm like you guys should
uh
did you calm down you might want to slow
down and they're like we love the they
taste delicious
I find This Woman's later I find it I
hope you enjoyed the muffins be careful
the small ones are 400 milligrams oh
[__] and the big ones are 600.
600 so much 600 but multiple oh you're
18 real quick I don't know I I don't
think anyone ate multiples oh okay okay
but I I don't I think they look I think
at most you can buy a 10 milligram yeah
right
oh over there yeah and or something like
I I don't they're not eating
that's horrible dude 400 milligrams When
You're Expecting 20. someone had a bad
night yeah I do someone had somebody
that we gave one to he might eat in the
600 one
he had also taken some acid oh he's
probably okay his buddies took took some
pictures of him later
just wrecked
you ever hear of the person you got to
see the update holy [__]
it's a rare moment
yeah terrifying that tour was with him
was the
like
one of the best experiences I'll tell
you what else has been happening
it's been so cool my oldest son has been
joining us a lot more nice on the road
which has been so cool you know he was
in the Army for a while so he he was
he couldn't come out yeah and so uh he's
been joining us a bunch more which is a
ton of fun he's gonna I'm gonna see him
in Texas and
October what's his name again Trevor
nice and he's doing comedy no Trevor's
not he comes and tells here's the thing
they all when they come
they hop on stage and so when Beth comes
up I always make sure that I do a little
bit with her on stage I like it man
that's awesome it's your whole family
going you know what yeah everybody like
this you guys like this
my daughter who I think is the funniest
out of the three of them
just hasn't
we did a tick tock Series where I put
she found a picture on the internet of
somebody's whose face was made up
and um sent brought it to me I had to go
to Sephora find makeup
and this woman helped me out and I was
like just don't tell me what anything
does look at this picture
tell put Wayne what I need
and then I'll try to figure it out
that's a pretty cool game you look like
a mess let me tell you
how horrible it turned out it was so I
wish I had the picture to show you send
it to us we'll put it over the screen
can I tell you man she's such a good
sport but like
around the eyes because I had to glue
some eye
whatever lashes on her oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry not on you yeah I I the makeup's
not on you yeah but I had to glue it on
her no I'm saying you're doing this to
her yeah
I thought the whole time you were doing
it to yourself
there it is yeah that's how it ended up
now In fairness do you want to see the
picture she sent me it should be on
there the picture she sent me is it
uh maybe I I mean I probably have it
dude
I thought this whole story you were like
no on myself
it's even worse she's a good sport damn
that's what you meant listen she is a
good sport
you let you do that
she's the best dude she's the how old is
she she's 29. oh she was so young that's
the picture she is supposed to look like
oh bro that was like an AI photo yeah it
does yeah well it's all perfect yeah
yeah and then that's the one I did
yeah people think I look young
I thought you were gonna say maybe in
the teens yeah
30 this year is that right wow that
looks like Andy Milonakis syndrome she
looks so young I always say like yeah I
know I look young bro he's my card like
no okay thank you catch me I don't see
that often she's really young super
smart
super funny
that was her idea
I love how she pitched it then you put
the makeup on me yeah yeah yeah I
respect that yeah I mean that's funnier
her putting it on me I'm gonna look okay
I'm gonna look okay
she knows she's doing see these are the
things I wouldn't have thought of and so
yeah it's funny so like but I know I'm
gonna be terrible
I've seen your drawings bro you're good
yeah
but that's like being humble yeah yeah
you
you've seen what I can do with it Josh
did this artwork man again a million
tries same I was in tears last episode
I'm sorry Josh was going to appreciate
those we realized there's a dick look
right by the you there's a little dick
and then look at the pizza it looks like
it's dripping oh and then look at
Homer's mouth open at the bottom waiting
for it oh bro what did we do to
ourselves he's getting a drop of each
it's crazy yeah it's a little dick
hanging off he's getting a little we
hate it a drop of pizza dude every time
I see him like pepperoni dick yeah he's
in dick I know I can't unsee it I can't
unsee it either yeah that is amazing yo
you are doing a set tonight also correct
oh yeah yeah yeah and you're not on
mushrooms tonight because you did
mushrooms last night like when it's like
when like older men take oh I gotta take
this you know this antacid because I'm
gonna eat eat at the barbecue tonight
this motherfucker's like I might go to a
podcast let me take three grams of just
your case Justin kicks
I'm on call guys I don't [__] around
yeah that's right that's right you
really are living just for fun right now
I am that's amazing yeah well listen you
know I told you I said I'm gonna take
some mushrooms mushrooms you did say
that yeah and I I
last time I think the mushrooms
gradually hit us right oh what was worse
after you left yeah yeah yeah so I
wanted to come in
just high and just just you just get
higher from there the cowboy jacket
really set it off too yeah
oh dude I wish I had brought the [__]
tassels it's got to be your signature
you do it on a hat a tassel jacket you
know I I found in a gas station in New
Mexico
[Music]
oh
yeah I got a jacket like that yeah
how the [__] did you know that
yo where are we at
I'm high yeah yeah no offense that was
you yo that was 100 you just told me
like some weirdo [__] like that that was
today oh my wait a second
yeah you're right yeah
that tonight correct oh yes I do yes I
do at what time
8 30. what time is it now
almost seven yeah we should probably
wrap it up so Josh has got holidays
coming up too by the way you're going to
want to check comedian joshwolf.com we
got Joshua Ohio Vegas Tampa we got
[__] Des Moines and followed by
New Brunswick damn in Erie PA in
Nashville I mean back to Vegas in
Jacksonville Orlando check out the
website for tickets oh and check out
listen Jacob and I do a podcast call hey
man oh the mo the most important it
would be amazing
um look I I and we reaction we're not
over Zoom anymore so it looks and it
sounds perfect
and uh it's
because
it's a lot it's funny but also like he
admits things to me every show which is
funny that he did that I didn't know it
looks good but he also like
um
we have serious talks like we had to
talk about his health the other day
but like just because I somebody told me
a dad after the show after my live show
he was like hey just want you to know
he'd come with his son and he was like
hey
my son's never asked me to do anything
with him before so really thank you for
what you guys are doing and I was like
oh and he was like it's inspirational
and inspirational
I'm pretty hot
I just did the same thing about Uber so
don't worry someone just told me about
some crazy Uber traffic
so don't worry I did it 10 seconds hey
um but the podcast is a ton of fun hey
man with three A's Three A's if you're
looking for it because you do say that
and you know you do text like that too I
do I do hey
man
I read it every single time yeah hey man
hey how are we doing mushrooms later
I did text you that earlier I was about
to film oh [__] I guess the last time
I'm scared the [__] out of me you but it
was so funny dude oh this was fun but
after it was crazy do you do you get
should we the next time we come in Jacob
and I shrooms I'll we'll take some jams
yeah for sure I think that's that's the
only time we could do that a reasonable
it's you a reasonable amount of
mushrooms is two grams for us to compute
yeah hang out yeah and just be normal
humans normal see normal human beings
yeah that's how I like to say it too I
think you're normal human I think you
definitely ate more than three grams
that night I don't even know but I what
I do I think it was the gummies you gave
me they were so bad well you bust out a
whole separate butterscotch mid episode
they were so good yeah they they were
this that was the that's the thing when
they make them tasting so good it tastes
like no mushrooms at all yeah and
they're actually kind of good we're good
those those butterscotch were first I
think the ones from your grandmother
were kind of hard you had to like oh
don't break your [__] yeah yeah they're
soft yeah damn mushrooms I was like
that's not even gonna do anything that
just tastes good Joan you've already
looked like a doll when I saw him after
the show I'm like thanks for pulling it
down huh like that those glasses that's
those [__] eyes
that looks like a woman with sunburned
boobs
yeah yeah
nobody can see it nobody else can see
this yo hey man comes out when when do
you drop episodes we drop them up right
now twice a week we're gonna go down
twice a week right now we're thinking we
might go down to once a week because we
do one of them on the road but I think I
would rather film us doing something fun
in each City then do a podcast I'm doing
a podcast it's a closed environment
again unless you're walking around doing
it just yeah but just doing something
different I'm already we're already
showing him showing them um the podcast
so
I mean we do like to go out and do
stupid stupid [__] out I think that'd be
more fun you're right don't you think
right and
you don't juice it too hard like let yo
I can't wait for next week yeah but also
two times a week is so fun like yo I hit
you again in a few days
it does a give and take hit you again in
a few days or we win [__] did some
mini golfing and then wrecked a car on
purpose so type [__] in Vegas oh wait
you living it's good to mix it up I
think Cincinnati mix it up and I think
um it shows the relationship in a
different dynamic because we're
competitive with each other yeah you
guys know the show about it and we talk
[__] we talk [__] to each other and like
so it's fun like it's yeah it's kind of
fun
yeah yeah it's kind of fun it's so much
fun I like it's the best time it's the
best time I've ever had in my life that
I've been doing this I've been doing
this a long time that's so fun for the
audience I feel too
I'm saying I can see this relationship
should be Bill and go oh I get to go see
it in person
yeah man it and it's also like does I
say this about Jimmy Fallon whatever you
think about him
people like watching other people have
fun 100 and on his show people are
having fun that's why his Clips get a
gazillion views because you're gonna
watch a couple minutes of two human
beings three human beings however many
having a good time and who's not
watching that he spots do you know what
I mean 100 and so like
I think that's
I think that's important oh for [__]
sure right we totally agree that's why
we moved back here that's why we're back
yep just to be us do our thing because
that's what sells this show it's just
it's just what it is yeah that's the
whole point you were the first uh the
first guest ever on the show and like
there's a reason why we go you're back
in town please come on the show this is
like the whole vibe of that that's
supposed to do man yeah this is fun
there was a time we were talking about
[__] or [__] for a while yeah I mean
we all were trying to talk about the
definition or the grammar or the
pronunciation of [__] or [__] and
that's where I want to be it matters
[__] chat [__] chat [__] [__] chat
[__] yeah that's that's where we want to
be yeah I mean that's our wheelhouse
[__]
horizontally and vertically whatever you
want to [__] say [__] somewhere
I said guess what this is and he was
like I have no idea what that is what
your show did to me yeah I [__] on
myself
that's [__] on the back of my jeans from
your show last night and he was like
what the [__]
to get a text
what was his response I don't remember
the exact I'm paraphrasing for sure but
he was like what is that you know
because even if he thought it looked
like [__] on pants he'd probably be
thinking [__] on pants yeah he'd
probably be thinking well why is he
sending me this
so that's not that can't be what that is
is he saying it was a shitty ass show oh
yeah what was what's he what's he trying
Smith why are you just [__] jupit
everybody with those words about the
layup Marty
um so for the podcast you're trying to
do well if it's gonna be once a week
what day are you gonna stick with uh
Thursdays Thursdays is on YouTube and
all platforms yeah all right good [__]
on on your page or hey man's page itself
on my page on my YouTube channel for
right now and then it'll direct you to
the hey man channel amen and sign up and
subscribe it's a ton of work
it's fun man yeah it's fun it's fun and
that's the main thing about this like
Marty said the other day when we when we
got back like if anybody that ever been
on the show we're rooting for you for
life forever because if you came on the
show we'd like you and if you left we're
still talking about you hear the [__]
and you're awesome so like we everything
you guys do we're we pay attention we
watch it we just want
and to see Jake come from just you know
hey I'm gonna come and watch the show
now he's doing a show and now he's on
stage with you guys it's a whole nother
level and layer to this it's so cool man
it's cool to see I appreciate it dude in
this and I said this to you guys was it
off the air when I told you how [__]
happy I am for you guys was that off the
air I don't remember I think so yeah I
think it might have been
I will say this I've told you this I
might tell you every time I'm here I
think but you're good guys man and I've
met a lot of people in this business and
a lot of people who don't do things the
right way and who what tells me about
who you are is you being back here
that's like that tells me so much about
who you got but you're a good dude
you've always done things the right way
you're good to your people you're always
a good vibe when you walk in here I'm
extremely happy for both of you guys man
yeah thank you it's super cool to see I
just like seeing it's like all the
high-ass fun people are doing really
well right now it's prevailing
yeah that's right and and
every week I'll get like a burst of
comments from that very first show
that you and I did in my backyard
wow every every week yeah where I was
the one who was too high on mushrooms
it's always just gonna be like it it's
forever there
so you can always go back no matter what
time it is go dude there was this one
you want to see this watch this there's
a play car show like you know the point
where you watch it back like that's
always gone now yeah he's outer space
now you can see where people just go
the original it Tim Curry and they're
gone and I can tell when it's you and I
think that's like you said I want to
bond with my kid to take much I feel
like the first time we ever took
mushrooms together was intense intense
mushrooms like you know what yeah I
realize that you're a nice person
yeah that's right that's right right
here in the back yeah I saw comments
like asking about that like no you guys
met before the podcast even started
that's why you're the First cast yeah oh
yeah that's the whole this whole reason
we thought like
by the way I couldn't believe that was
your first one like you're you're yeah
you're not by the way the you joining
and not being over there is so much
better yeah dude it's so much so much
better with yourself and not only that
dude the people who watch and listen
like you that's that that that and like
they like you I'm always like what are
you right right yeah just be right here
yeah yeah yeah thank you when you look
at your social media like you're clearly
yeah yeah so this is the exact right
spot thank you sir it's much better like
this huh yeah I love it and like we said
with Jake wait I'm so glad Jake's like
doing this [__] now he's afraid to be
popping in like dude I could see your
ass Crow through clips and YouTube
videos it's very cool to see because you
said like if you're doing it the right
way this is the most organic [__] that
you guys are doing it's like you know
what I think you should start doing this
as a career because you can make money
and like yo here's doing Netflix shows
and I'm [__] in Africa or whatever he
was doing cool [__] it's like you know
what I'm gonna do cool [__] at home
mom's cranking out movies and [__] I'm
not sure you guys are crushing on all
fronts right now this is very cool to
see yeah it feels really weird
oh yeah it does feel really on your face
I
feels good all the way around everybody
in the family is happy and healthy
that's goals for people wanting to like
you know you guys are all doing what you
want you're involving each other you're
spending your time together you're all
just chilling like that's goals friendly
Jackson Five you guys are crushing it
right now yeah I'm forcing everybody to
do [__] but not one of us can dance
well I think Jacob running man yeah you
just disproof
yeah I mean hold on
bro you're a tick tock Legend already
yeah right there that's that's it you
just need that one right there I can I
can uh I would probably break my back
right now
yeah I mean let's be honest I tried to
do some sort of there'd be a some sort
of crack
somewhere and it would be followed by
help me up and that would be it that
would be the end of that Dance I mean I
almost pulled a muscle during The
Running Man
hey it wasn't already man it was a
perfect running man what would you just
just do me a favor name what you saw
the jogging man
it looked more like a bench press but it
looked like uh it was an athletic
demonstration the running press
the what does it say Tony Little the
gazelle like you're doing gazelle when
you were doing is that what it looked
like yeah but the two-fisted gazelle
that sounds dirty but it isn't oh but
or the ghost
yeah you're mine yeah that's what it was
it was a doctor oh yeah just pulling
people towards you but what about why
why were my legs like that if I was the
abductor
um that's like kickboxing cardio moves
like you're like the Billy Blanks yeah
yeah
Jacobs took karate away or take one over
there for real oh yeah yeah but he plays
all ball and kicking and [__] over that
place used to be in the valley he and
his brothers used to run it
[Laughter]
yo for a minute that was the [__] oh
my P90X was dog [__] compared to I'm not
saying results compared to how hyped up
oh Billy Blanks yeah all right we're
gonna come right here go turn his wrist
every time he was like the Power Ranger
to me dude his studio for a bit was
[__] jammed all the time people doing
taebo but he also took took uh taught
Taekwondo classes did you go fight her
like that uh I don't remember he didn't
teach any specifically I don't think he
he was teaching mostly taebo
um but like Jacob took Taekwondo classes
there Jacob used to be able to he could
fight he used to be able to I don't know
if he can fight but he used to be able
to walk into the splits
that he could do the splits like [__]
with those long ass I'll say those long
ass legs yeah those long ass legs it was
so crazy he could do it at the mall I
was like this is he could do it at the
mall yeah you might be his shoes really
weird dude yeah it was [__] like
creepy as [__]
I found your dick pics first time he did
it I thought he was broken I'm like
What's Happening
did the shocks just go out on this dude
I was like dude you have no more muscle
tone then what happened just did
everything just go away and he was like
oh but he was probably not at the time
nine oh yeah young he could do that I'm
picturing him right now doing this
that's the whole time
a little kid that's normal I used to try
to do the splits all the time and then
I'd do that so
see look how far look it dude I wasn't
doing yeah me neither it was that not
even that he could get to the splits but
that he could like walk in and not out
of him he was so far they had do you
know what I'm saying
so like that's ninja ship yeah yeah but
it was just like they were
he was so [__] oddly flexible he's
not flexible at all now
I mean wish I could dunk me too dark
yeah yeah he dunked on me oh no in the
driveway
and the first time he did it his nuts
were right
how old was he
and he
you know you have to cross the line and
come back to the
yeah take it out check it out takes it
out across the line and I'm hanging back
and he just comes right at me and I'm
like I think I still get some hops I'm
like I'm gonna block that [__]
and he [__] nutted me right now damn
on a 10-foot room yeah God damn he's
good they just [__] straight up good
I'll tell you something else I'll tell
you something else
so
so we were I'm not gonna say we were
okay we were I'm a zoo Jacob and I were
aware we were on the road and um this
woman was like uh
I bet you I can squat you and I was like
what what the [__] she goes I bet you I
can squat you
you okay if I squat you and we'll
videotape it and I was like
sure
so I think she's got a fireman Carry Me
she goes get on my shoulders like like I
need to see at a at a music festival do
you know what I mean
now she was a
it very in shape but
six one
very in shape them okay bigger one
and so
first of all she just [__] wait wait
nothing actually yeah maybe it was not
even an issue like it was nothing
so you're sitting on a woman's shoulders
at your own show this is this is after
the show of the meet and greet
when you got on her shoulders was there
any question uh yeah I thought I was
gonna first I thought I was going
backwards oh that's a possibility it
wasn't it did not feel good but we
figured it out
but I will tell you this
it
I know now why grown-ups grown men
you don't play chicken like that with
other dudes because there's no way to
avoid dick in the neck a hundred percent
no do you know what I'm saying sure this
just there's no way to avoid that's
where it's going this
and by nature of it I'm leaning forward
just a little bit and by nature
of the games I didn't I didn't think
about it until because she was her neck
was like this
I bent over when I get on and when I sit
up I'm like no dick and Nick that's not
but she did the [__] straight Squad
up and down
and uh was the strongest woman
but I think I've ever accept the woman
that in the bachelor party story that
beat up my buddy she's like the
strongest woman I was like how many of
those could you have done she was like
however many how much time you got yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a good answer
yeah yeah yeah yeah but but uh
real quick how do we get on this topic
I need to know oh you said we weren't
you and J you're not gonna say what city
you were in wow yeah it's a lady
squatted you yeah she squatted me I like
it I wish she had
but I I have people hold me a lot really
they like to hold me like a baby what
for some reason you're not small yeah it
doesn't matter it's always big giant men
then it is big dudes don't you think
it'll be funny if I hold you I'm like
this is your picture don't you think
it'd be funny if your ass is on my stuff
that's nice of you a lot of people don't
do that you know what man I
I I
for right now
the places I'm I'm playing are usually
not bigger than like 750 seats
and so that might take me a couple hours
and I do a free meet and greet that
might take me a couple hours but like
I'm not going right to sleep anyways and
so like
I I know who's on my list of people I
would leave my house to go see
so sure the fact yeah so the fact that
anybody I'm on anyone's list is very
humbling so if the least I can do is go
out and say you won't I'm here if you
want to shake it and take a picture if
you want my dick on your neck listen
dude that's right free dick on the neck
you left your house for this duck
underneath that's a different line no
but she by the way this this woman was
super funny too
uh these women are I mean what a great
sense of humor for her to just be like
get on my shoulders like okay
I can imagine
I can only imagine you missed a great
story don't worry you'll watch it next
week
um damn sorry I know I know you gotta
get a magic sorry hey man podcast every
Thursday yeah you can find all the
episodes you want out there
and
and uh all the episodes are already up
there they're going to be on your
channel yeah my YouTube channel yeah or
you can just Google if you go onto
YouTube and you go hey man with three
A's with three A's it's in there all
right hey man pod on YouTube yeah and um
and then again it's on obviously iTunes
and Spotify and all that other [__] and
then uh come check us out on tour it's a
really fun Show comedian Josh wolf.com
for tour dates guys this has been
another episode I'm sorry it's been fun
shroomless
so we can actually compute later I mean
I can this guy's gonna go for four I'm
gonna hope to like make it home and
chill next time next time it'll be fun
we'll take some handlers and [__] next
time I won't drive we gotta have Nico
bring out all the crazy class for Josh
and sure enough for mushrooms all right
that'll be a separate episode separate
episode that'd be crazy we had a
we had an insane episode this guy
brought out the craziest rigs you could
ever see in your life dabbing it was a
wildest [__] it was fun which episode
was that two episodes ago all right you
should watch it's pretty it's pretty
insane if you're on the flights check it
out what a great thing to watch four
hours long that's why we filled a bag up
with weed [__] every 10 minutes we pick
something out we all smoked it or ate it
every 10 minutes it was incredible
that's amazing if you think we can get
through it we can do something like that
next time if it's not just mushrooms
because mushrooms I don't think we can
do a bag of weed [__] yeah I'm being
outer space
I don't know listen it's your show yeah
he's down for whatever yeah he basically
said you'll attempt yeah I mean I mean I
I'm not do I look like a guy who says no
yeah I'm here for a good [__] yeah
yeah I mean I know why I'm here let's
rock and roll all right see you next
time oh man yeah [__] we can do whatever
I mean listen we can do both at some
time you know we'll do them both at the
same time at the same time back to back
yeah
I mean that scene in one episode and
then we'll all get belligerent
your face same I finally said something
that made you go oh
same one back to back would be I mean we
could do that we do the mushrooms first
first and then halfway in the episode
start taking all the weed [__] let's
figure this out I think I can get
something fun done
it sounds [__] fun to me okay yeah
figure it out yeah yeah and then we'll
uh
I mean we'll be back Jacob and I will be
back here in July
oh in a month we're back here sometime
in July oh okay okay we'll figure it out
so thank you for having me on it's been
fun
do you ever have people on hey man
not yet but we're going to do a small
offshoot
called Fathers and Sons I just want to
talk to other dads and kids and I have
my my son OG we should bring him on I
talk about just whatever their
relationship is or how they interact
with each other or what they've learned
like it could be like a fun slightly
slash therapy session for these kids but
but also like a cool discussion to see
how other people do it and like
what their experience as a kid was what
they thought the parent could have done
better
do you know what I mean here's maybe
what I've never said to you or just
talked to whatever it'd just be cool and
then eventually I think because I think
a good podcast has kind of a
a point of view going in and it can
broaden out and then eventually
and what I mean eventually it could be
the second episode it could be a mother
and her daughter or mother and her son
it's just the idea of like it's a I
don't know I think it could be something
cool
the idea of like an open forum
do you know I mean and Jacob being there
almost gives the the kid like permission
to yeah
really too automatically if you're in
the same exact position on the same
cameras yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so that's how they can relate with I'll
probably do like five
just to see what they're like yeah and
how I can make it better right and
before I I think you're ready
oh okay I got what you're saying to make
sure you like it first but just to make
sure like I because the first time I do
it I might only like be like I'm Gonna
Keep 20 of that yeah
so I this I think because it's a cool
opportunity
for something different I want to make
sure that when I put it out I know what
I'm doing
how he and I do it together is going to
be really important all that stuff so I
want to make sure I get those Kinks out
but I think it's gonna be I think it
could be super dope yeah of course
anything is to do that you like do for
fun first yeah and that could be super
you know I mean like that's the at the
end but I think you make a lot of money
and I think a lot of you like no I think
it'd be super dope yeah that's the whole
point I appreciative fun right now
that's the best part and it grows gross
from here and here we are nobody's doing
it that I know of oh something like that
no no you do all the [__] you do is some
[__] you made up randomly and nobody's
ever done last time like let's uh wear
dresses and dunk on each other and [__]
there's a bunch of [__] you do that's
different right
that's true
in a ballerina costume it was the
ballerina costume that's what it was
yeah yeah still yeah I would do when
that old dude told me to pull up my top
pull up your top
so [__] funny uh yeah that show was a
ton of fun man again
I
is one of the one of the things I like
the most about nobody and you're here
right but you're your boss
you get to do what you
want to do yeah
what's better what's better than that I
wish that for everybody do you know what
I mean like this is your job 100 we say
it a lot actually I was really like
say it a lot as we lock up the little
game like damn yeah crazy it is it is
and you were here from the start and now
you hear from the new start so thank you
for coming thank you for having me I
appreciate it man thank you guys thank
you sir this feels awesome I'm so glad
you're able to make this happen I can't
me too thank you Josh Josh uh comedian
Josh wolf.com for all tickets yep all
right Thursdays hey man with three A's
drops all right podcast with him and
Jake wolf thank you so much Marty thank
you sir I'm so happy we could do this
this feels right it makes me feel
energized yeah thank you I'm excited
thank you guys for being here appreciate
it mushroomless episode guys I feel like
we got through it we got through it good
yeah yeah yeah it's good for four and a
half hours you missed your show for sure
yeah yeah yeah oh I have a show tonight
are you thank you for me thank you Josh
thank you for being here yeah guys
podcast thank you so much for being here
have a best day you you sir
Jake Jake is the guy like yo he makes
sure that time he's on oh we're going to
shows we're [__] eating this dude he
knows me
[Music]
perfect